on the ground over
here
[Applause]
I just want you to like just look at how
calm it gets bro like there's no
cortisol in the blood
is always what happens when you get
super like ramped up and scared right
yeah yeah
this is tallest mission
total submission this guy is ready for
anything
[Music]
be done to him and he's not nervous he's
not resisting
he's in total relaxation
no Panic hormones whatsoever
see I let him go he gets up
so I know that you guys don't eat pigs
and stuff because they're dirty animals
can you kind of expand upon that and I'm
just asking these questions because like
this is the stuff that you know a lot of
Americans would wonder when looking into
the life of you know Muslims
yeah yeah so I want to talk about it
from an assigned perspective then I
think five might be better versed on it
it's kind of the health you should we
should also talk about how it's not just
Muslims bro
that's a great point that is a very good
point I know Sonny fast said you guys
and I know I know you you see that
because I don't blame you bro Muslims
are a force today that that we actually
follow what's written you know but this
is not to throw there on any other
religion but it's actually not something
that just stems from Islam 1400 years
ago it's actually just something that's
always been a part of God's law
but so why pigs specifically other than
animals like cows or chickens
yeah so firstly I want to give an
Islamic kind of explanation so Allah and
the prophet peace be upon him
when anything is made Haram we're told
not to do this you know this is Haram or
we told we're told to do something and
we need to do it we aren't always given
a reason right for example
the process doesn't always say this is
Haram because of this and because of
that so that leaves room one for us to
just say Allah is the most knowledgeable
Allah is is the all-knowing and the most
wise if he says something is Haram it's
for a good reason and I will obey God
because I submit to God and his will
and sometimes there is a reason given
but when there isn't it's up to us to
basically extract wisdoms behind it you
know if I were to eat pork this might
happen that might happen this could
happen and this could be from the wisdom
of why God did not allow us to eat it
and I think if you've read the studies
you see that pork is a tremendously
horrible thing to eat for you it's not
good for you yeah for your health and
fine if you want to go into that and
talk about some of the uh the cons to
eating yeah I mean guys I can I can do a
lot of research that I've compiled
before and I can just put a link in the
description but simply put the way that
pork is preserved the way it's handled
when you look at like you know FDA
regulations on Animal Control when you
look at you know just the bacteria when
you look at the pathogens that it has
the way it's prepared when you look at
sausages
um I was even even in TV shows bro like
there was this one TV show called house
and it's like a medical show a lot of
people watch you know these are
mainstream shows and it just shows one
kid that just ended up in the hospital
and they couldn't find the cause about
it but they found out that for a long
period of time they were having
basically pork like just sausages you
know and the way it's preserved Frozen
it's a very dirty type of meat what do
you expect from an animal that eats its
own fecal matter you know what I mean
yeah you can't be surprised when you get
sick
it kind of ties into a lot about like I
wanted to play a video bro it's a quick
like two three minute video it's nothing
too long I think Anna already knows what
I'm about to play um but it's something
that I like showing a lot of people
because not most of us bro they come
into Islam and they wonder why do you
guys have this thing called halal meat
you know what does halal meat is it just
like something that's like blessed you
know why is there so much segregation
you know meat is meat some people also
think that okay if you guys are Muslim
you don't eat pork cool at least you
know you guys eat chicken right you guys
eat beef but we have a specific way of
slaughtering the meat which is halal me
I'm sure you've heard about it
um so I do want Romney to talk a little
bit about halal meat
um if you don't mind and then I'll just
put the video up bro inshallah
all right so halal meat as far as I know
it's just it's meat that's slotted in a
very specific way as according to Allah
and his messenger revealed and with
basically the name of God and Praises of
God being recited um when the animal is
killed so you'll find in a lot of these
places that non-muslims that slaughter
their animals some that even claim to be
you know practicing Muslims or
Christians or whatever they they have
disgusting disgusting disgusting
um you know regulations and very very
disgusting
uh what's it called
methods of killing the animals yeah
that's crazy exactly methods yeah like
bullet in the head and you can see the
animals are strong losing its mind and
and going crazy right before it's dead
in Islam we don't even let the animals
see the blade in our hand
we separate it from the entire flock and
we take it into a place where it's alone
we basically get it to lie down we cover
its eyes we get it so that's relaxed we
recite a prayer it doesn't even see the
blade and then it's just a quick slice
of the throat and the arteries here and
that does a few things one I I don't
know if this is how accurate this is but
I heard that it cuts off a certain nerve
so the animal doesn't feel a certain
pain or something I'm not sure if that's
that's accurate I've heard that recently
and secondly it allows the blood to flow
out because diseases are carried to the
blood so the more blood you drain out
the cleaner the the meat is going to be
and you're not going to have all those
hormones of the animal freaking out you
know according to the meat and that
stuff like I've heard recently it
happens a lot bro that's that's facts 97
to 98 of all animal related illnesses
are bloodborne
but I do want to hear you know what you
were going to say now but we're
basically going to show you like a
demonstration of what a halal meat
slaughtering looks like
and and how the animal literally submits
like there's no cortisol in the body of
the of the animal and we want to get
your thoughts on that but what are you
going to say bro
no it's just it's really interesting
stuff
um
what was I gonna ask I'm blanking right
now I'm such a dummy sometimes you can
just play the video it'll come back to
me
no worries bro no worries inshallah it's
been a long day
no I gotta I get it so I'm just air
dropping the video it should take
another like I remember what what do you
guys think of vaccines in Islam
because that's what sticks with your
blood for years and that's what you know
can can change your blood a lot it's
getting all right so no no no questions
on the JibJab
on this yeah on this channel that's why
we got our first uh strike but here's
the thing bro if you want to have a raw
unfiltered conversation about that we
can post that on our website so we've
actually been thinking lately of posting
more unfiltered uncensored things that
you know we can't really say on every
website and post it on our Channel
inshallah I think it being centered kind
of tells you what you need to know but
yeah we can do that separately but I'll
put the video right now
take a look at that
okay
okay
God's blessings and mercy upon you all
my human brothers and sisters today I'm
going to share with you a video an
amazing video of two parts
about the authentic Islamic Slaughter
procedure on lambs and goats on the
first video we're going to illustrate
the power of God's name as the only
method of submission before Slaughter
on the second video we're going to show
you the authentic Islam the complete
authentic Islamic Slaughter procedure
only using God's name upon Slaughter
exactly the same way the all the
prophets have done for thousands years
Abraham Noah
Moses Jesus and Muhammad peace upon all
of them
not using stun guns or hammers or any
other equipment's electrical equipments
only using simply only using God's name
upon Slaughter
before we appreciate I would like to
mention that all the scriptures Torah
Bible and Quran has been preaching of
one God he is the CR he is the only
creator of all creations and he is the
one that worthy of being worshiped and
thanked by all his creations and he also
created lambs and goats as a blessing
for humans
for the purpose of food and clothing
the scriptures also preaches about
Humane treatment of animals and as a
humans we only have the right to
slaughter him in God's name to be
mentions before Slaughter God's name can
be mentioned in different languages and
it will have the same effect you can say
God's name in English Arabic Hebrew
French Chinese as long as the slaughter
have a strong faith in the world itself
and of the Creator and mention it it
will have the same effect and the same
submission effect of the animals it's an
amazing word and it will have the same
effect in different languages
these animals are bilingual and they all
know God's name when it's mentioned no
matter what language and they always
feel the heart of that Slaughter if he
believes in that word or he doesn't
wants to believe in there the faith is
there and the word is mentioned is
guaranteed
affect and a guaranteed submission
let's go
we're going to take these animals run
them inside as a group we're not going
to separate an animal from each other
um
every animal every Creations would like
to have a partner except the almighty
Lord so to really maintain these animals
to be calm you always have to try to
make him travel with a group you don't
separate anyone from the other
definitely not one by himself that would
really make him very tense it has to be
two or more minimal okay what we're
gonna do we're gonna take the uh
Mama's we're gonna bring him over here
and we're gonna make him submit
on the ground
foreign
[Applause]
I just want you to like just look at how
calm it gets bro like there's no
cortisol in the blood
is what happens when you when you are
like ramped up and scared right
yeah yeah
this is total submission
total submission this guy is ready for
anything
to be done to him and he's not nervous
he's not resisting
he's in total relaxation
no Panic hormones whatsoever
see I let him go he gets up
to a skeptical person
okay baby it's okay I'm not doing
anything good Bismillah
it's okay baby
same reaction they all react the same
the power of the word
[Music]
they're more religious than most humans
[Music]
money
[Music]
Liberty
[Music]
Bismillah
[Music]
total submission
foreign
bigger ranchers so they're a little bit
wild they're not used to be touched and
handled by humans
and uh for them to turn around and just
lay down like
really in total peace
answering the calling
definitely
the power of the word my not
[Music]
wow
[Music]
today
[Music]
oh this is the big boy this guy
in the auction when we bought him from
our Rancher it weighed over 300 pounds
and it's usually
get away more now because
he was fed and he's been having fun
eating Alfalfa and everything he's
probably 10 pounds larger than what it
was in the auction
I weigh 190 pounds
so any dealing with this guy he has to
help out otherwise there's no chance
anybody can really restrain him or force
him to do anything that he doesn't want
to do
he's gonna do exactly what he instantly
wants to do
so this guy submit
the power of the word is clear
this is a 300 pound animal for me to
drop him down on the floor to start
submission
it's almost impossible for one person to
do it
to help out
for the initial submission and then he's
gonna withdraw and the animal is gonna
respond by himself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
I'm putting only a finger
on the ear
and this guy if he wants to get up I
don't think any anybody is capable
to get him back down except two people
as strong as me and abdulrahed
to be able to submit this animal on the
floor but now
is totally answering the calling
he's happy with it
snow breathing hard if you know that
the idea that's that's really
interesting it's it's pretty sad to see
that and then think about
how that's how it's like kind of meant
to be but how
in the you know the big Industries
Industries and stuff it's the complete
opposite and they do horrible things to
the animals that's right
I've never seen that that's wild
when you look at like animal production
today you know McDonald's Burger King
all these different you know Mass
consumerism there's no way they can
invest in that bro in halal slaughtering
like that to make the quick Buck whereas
you know stun guns and machines and
factories if you if you really watch the
documentaries about how they keep
chickens bro there's there's like a
certain amount of square footage that a
chicken should have to have an optimal
life you know and they have I think like
two or three chickens per square foot
that's like the amount of room they get
yeah no it's it's insane I've seen a lot
of those documentaries it's horrible
what they do yeah 100 and it's this is a
very clear example of how things should
be done versus how they actually are
done but suddenly think about all the
other Industries in life where people
are doing it completely wrong you don't
think